you
we've been connecting our environment to
the internet since the Internet's been
around but I think the reason why it's
becoming so exciting now is that
effectively you know smartphones have
basically commoditized this wonderful
stack of Technology from processing to
memory to communications that now is so
cheap we can take a little mini
smartphone stack and embed it in all
sorts of things in our houses in our
cars on our bodies and so now we can
literally make computing environments
that live in our homes we can turn our
office building into a compute
environment and that means there are you
know there's a UI for how you interact
with your office building there are a
pis for how other technologies can get
information from the office building in
order to sort of have the Internet of
Things you know I think these
interesting it as it is it not only
needs this smart sort of you know stack
of technology on the sort of the
processing and networking side but you
also need a lot of sensor technology
I've been fortunate to have worked with
a couple of I think some of the more
exciting early successes and the
Internet of Things you know one of them
more you know well-known ones is nest
and some nest you know is a really
incredible team who built the Apple
iPhone and so these guys really knew how
to not only make a really intelligent
smart connected device but also how to
make something that really appeals to
consumers and you know the smart thing
they did is they they said that you know
the thermostat shouldn't just be a dumb
switch on your wall it's going to be a
sensing intelligent you know connected
you know smart phone that manages your
temperature and all sorts of things in
your house and they put some sensors in
this product that allowed them to
determine you know are you home or not
and can we take action based on on the
occupancy of your home and if you're not
home you know this is a relatively
simple idea but if you're not home we're
going to turn you know up or down the
temperature so if it's the winter we're
going to go ahead and let the house cool
down and then when you come home well
naturally will detect your home and
we're going to heat it up for you and so
it's just some of this against smart
detection and understanding of occupancy
and then some really basic learning
technologies that allows them to sort of
predict and react and understand
consumer preferences that then makes the
device really work for the customer so
it's not it's not adding complexity it's
actually simplifying your life
the way I think about it is I feel like
it's sort of the next frontier of
innovation and you know if you look back
historically at waves of innovation in
Silicon Valley you know they're very
pretty clearly defined by there's a
there's a big hardware innovation
whether it's you know hard disk drives
or you know pcs and Internet networking
equipment and then that enables a really
long period of software innovation on
top of that big leap forward and
hardware platforms and so for me the
Internet of Things is really kind of
that next new platform area post you
know the iPhone you know the smartphone
and the tablet ecosystem and so right
now what we're seeing is a bit of the
Wild West people are trying to figure
out so you know what are what's what's
the standard look like what are the
communication standards and you know to
complicate things there isn't sort of
one specific instantiation of this
platform there's lots of different
things so Internet of Things is going to
look really different in a residential
situation versus you know an industrial
situation and so you know I see this as
the super super early days and you know
this this is a period that's going to
last for quite some time
another way to think about this is you
know in the really beginnings of new
areas of innovation you tend to see very
vertically integrated companies
companies that you know if I'm going to
make a smart thermostat I have to do
everything because they're you know this
is a new part of the industry and so
everything from the firmware to you know
all the hardware to the software and and
so these are really big undertakings and
and then you know over time as more
companies find success there will be
pieces of that tech architecture that
get picked off and turned into services
and you know then we'll start to see
sort of some of those horizontal
technologies you know for example one
that I think makes a ton of sense to
sort of horizontal eyes sooner rather
than later is just that you know this
notion of I want to connect something to
the internet like a Wi-Fi on-demand
Wi-Fi connection on demand you know
almost a it's like a whisper net as
service kind of thing and so I suspect
we'll start to see some companies that
go after these technology layers but
it's hard to lead with that and you know
when it's still the Wild West and people
don't really understand you know what
are the killer apps and how are
consumers going to be interacting with
these things what really gets me excited
as an investor in the Internet of Things
is I think they're it enables some
really interesting new business models
so you know one company that I'm on the
board of is called enlighted and it's
easiest described as sort of nest for
commercial buildings and they put a
sensor at every light in the building
and these sensors allow them to control
energy use on lighting based on
occupancy but then they can also do
things like controlling HVAC they can
understand the the you know the
occupancy of the buildings themselves
and then they can do a lot of other
things around security and space
planning and so when you take a step
back what's exciting about what the
technology enables is that by putting in
this Hardware sensing platform you're
getting some proprietary new data that
you otherwise wouldn't be able to get
and then once you have this data you can
then build a series of software
applications that provide different
insights to the business owner around
different areas of their business and so
ultimately I'm really intrigued by
Internet of Things opportunities where
again the hardware is purely unlocking
some more information buried around us
that enables us to then build really
valuable software businesses
that's where we have to be just really
careful about how we implement these
things and you know we want to implement
you know the right amount of data to be
able to take action and do the right
things for the customer but not too much
where we cross any kind of line now you
know we're self limited when it comes to
Internet of Things because if you're
outfitting you know 100,000 square feet
of floor space with sensors guaranteed
you're actually being really selective
about what data you're you're actually
bringing back and so you know again it's
just about being very targeted and
focused on again the specific
application so you're not just
collecting all types of data for data
sake in enlighted situation you know
frankly the big insight really is
occupancy and understanding how people
are using buildings but occupancy is
harder to understand then than you'd
think and right now you've got these
very basic occupancy sensors that
everyone's familiar with in their office
where you know after 10 minutes of not
moving the you know the lights go off
and you're like I'm still here and yeah
and so the problem with those sensors is
they're they're you know pretty low
resolution and so the key is how do you
find sensors that really understand you
know there's there's a human who's
sitting in the office who's sitting very
still and so you know getting a lot of
better granularity around sensing is
really important and that's part of you
know again the technology embedded in
the Internet of Things but once you have
really good high-resolution data around
occupancy you know you can really
dramatically change you know the how the
building operates and you know one of
the things we talked about with this
enlighted company is you know we're
helping redefine the future of the at
work environment so when you come into
your office it knows you're there it's
adjusted for you the lights set to your
level the temperature set to your
temperature you know there's a bunch of
things that can be accommodated to
ultimately make it a better work
experience for the person who's in that
office but then for the company
themselves you know what we've shown so
far that when we install these sensors
and the lie
you know we save 50 to 70% all lighting
energy dramatic dramatic energy
reduction simply by just shaving off you
know lighting usage when people aren't
actually using rooms and just very
simple things like that we can also do
you know a similar not quite as much
savings but similar things around energy
as well so the environmental
implications of this kind of Internet of
Things a deployment is massive and
doesn't put the customer out in any way
so I love the fact that as a customer
you're not sacrificing you know for you
know the lights to sort of control and
turn off when you're not in a room and
so it's just the building being much
much smarter about how it's being used